good morning everyone my name is TJ
alumbaugh I am a developer at continuum
and this talk is about building tax
brain so I think it's maybe one part
community story you know here's what
this community is doing with the numpy
stack to do something good for society
one part kind of a recipe if you are
interested in doing this kind of thing
kind of a numerical or a number of
crunching Python package and putting it
on the web I think this this could serve
as a recipe for how to do that and then
maybe one part advice of the these are
some problems that we encountered and
here's how we worked around that so
here's what we're going to do today I
just want to walk you through the
background of what what are we trying to
accomplish here what's the motivation
for this talk a little bit about a
Python package that we built that's
called tax calc it's a tax calculator
I'll talk briefly about how we use numba
in that package okay I see a show of
hands anyone who would consider yourself
the number user or it's used number
before okay so just a couple of people
and then I'll do a little bit of a demo
about how we and show you this
application running live and then I'll
talk about some deployment issues which
are very challenging a lot of times when
you want to do something like this some
lessons that we learned from all that
and then show you where we hope to go in
the future and some acknowledgments to
end off so first the background so what
is this all about well this work is
sponsored by the open-source policy
center or ospc ospc is a community with
a goal of making policy analysis more
trustworthy accessible and innovative by
harnessing open-source minus the all of
the great benefits that all the people
in this room have leveraged from the
open source movement this organization
wants to apply that to the world of
making policy and in particular to
making computational economic models
open source so what what is the state of
the world open source is sort of the de
facto in in pipe and the PI data world
what about other worlds well one world
is the world of policy and it turns out
that everyone in this room is very
strongly affected by computational
economic models these are models that
determine what's going to happen if you
change tax rates these are models that
we predict health care spending these
are models that are going to predict
social security spending and those
policies are affected by models and what
we think is going to happen in the
future and those policies then come into
law so the kinds of questions yeah i
mean what how should we spend the the
money that the government brings in or
how should we raise money who's going to
win and who's going to lose who's going
to gain what's going to happen to the
economy if you do various things so so
that's that the that current state of
the world it uses economic models that
are proprietary software and
policymakers and the public don't have
access so this includes the people that
don't do not have access to the source
code are people like members of Congress
people who are presidential candidates
they have policies that are based on
models where the source code is not
accessible even to those folks and this
even includes the government paying for
the for the development of models in
code where the code stays proprietary
and is not open source so um there's a
lot of bad things that happen from that
it inhibits create a policy solution so
we're not harnessing all the brains that
we could be if we put the code up online
it limits participation and that's and
that's bad for democracy it's bad for
the democratic process it inhibits
external review so we can't have someone
go and look and find a there's a problem
in in your code there's a bug because we
just don't have as many eyes because
it's a closed source solution and so we
might be missing out on an opportunity
for a more
optimum policy and that's bad for our
economy so that's that's the motivation
for what the ospc organizations trying
to do they've asked continuum to come
alongside and help them achieve that
goal and so the first thing that we've
built is a tax calculator and so that's
a Python package it's called tax calc
it's an implementation of the federal
income tax codes a full implementation
of the tax code which is of course a
moving target in that that you know we
have the tax code for various years so
from about twenty thirteen to about
twenty twenty four ish uh you know
depending on inflation rates and you
know potential policy changes and things
like that but but that's kind of the
time window where we would say we are at
faithful to the federal income tax code
law the current tax law so what what is
this kind of calculation it's known as a
micro economic simulation or a micro
simulation and it answers very basic
questions like this it's a very
straightforward calculation what happens
if we raise the capital gains tax how
much revenue could we expect to get or
lower it you know raise or lower the
maximum taxable income for Social
Security or the highest tax rate you
know we were to tax the highest earners
more what what do you expect to get from
that I or you know one of the main
things would be a how do you create a
revenue neutral policy right so we want
to incentivize some other behavior so
we're going to create a text tax cut
over here but maybe we'll compensate for
that by raising taxes in another area so
how do you make sure that's where every
new neutral where you need to use a
model of some kind so this is a very
simple calculation and the way that it
works is you start with some sample tax
returns that are hopefully
representative of the real data set of
all the tax returns that we get and i'll
explain more about that in a minute you
take the set of tax code parameters that
is you know this is the current income
tax rate for all these brackets and all
these other host of parameters and you
put those two things together and that's
what we compute in tax calc
and then you end up with a revenue
projection this is how much revenue we
believe we're going to get so what is
that sample set of data well it turns
out that there is this thing called the
public use file it where the puff and
the puff is a licensed data set that is
made available by the statistics of
income division of the IRS so if you pay
taxes in the United States that's your
tax dollars at work and it's basically
about a hundred and fifty thousand or so
sample tax returns with these privacy
enhancing modifications so in other
words they do certain things there are
certain people in the IRS that take real
tax returns modify them so for example
if you looked closely enough you might
be able to discern who a particular tax
return belongs to maybe for some
extremely high or something like that so
they make some changes of that to you
know protect people's privacy and then
it's also waited to be statistically
similar to the full set of tax returns
which is about 120 ish million tax
returns process every year so the way
that works is that there's an extra
column of data in this data set that is
a weight so so for example for one of
the tax returns where the income level
is maybe between fifty and sixty
thousand which is sort of a national you
know in the average mean mean income
maybe the weight for that record would
be three hundred thousand that'll
represent three hundred thousand
individual tax returns or something but
for another returning that in the data
set that is you know maybe has two
million adjusted gross income that that
would be a weight of like five or six or
something like that so that way in a
weighted sense we basically have about
120 million different tax returns so how
does the tax calculator perform you know
this this policy analysis really what
would happen what would happen if we did
your your policy idea what we do is the
top is the chart we just showed you
take down i'll just call it the puff
with the default tax code parameters and
apply tax calc to that and out comes the
standard you know if we did nothing here
is what the revenue would be the the
purple in the bottom is your user
specified tax code parameters so we want
to change the max taxable social
security income or something like that
or lower the capital gains tax and that
result is the blue a different revenue
projection and so your policy effect is
the Delta of that and actually we do
this for ten budget year so so really
when you you typically run this in
practice you would get ten Delta's right
so now I'll just briefly talk about how
we've applied numba in this package so
if you are I didn't get too many hands
for using numba so numba is a jitter or
just-in-time compiler for compiling fat
Python code excuse me so the general
idea is that you know a lot of people in
this room probably use a numpy and if
you so there are certain kinds of
operations that are great with them by
and there are other kinds of operations
with numpy that are very challenging and
result in code that doesn't look so
great so one of those would be you know
if you wanted to have an if statement or
a logical and or logical or on an
element wise basis you want to check
that condition and you do not want to do
a for loop over a numpy ray in Python
because that completely kills all the
performance you were getting by using
numpy so therefore you end up with code
that looks like this which is when ospc
came to our doors they had a bunch of
code that looked very similar to this so
i think you can kind of seal that the NP
logical war NP where's all over the
place and this is definitely a way of
ensuring that you will never touch this
code again after you get it working
because it's very ugly right and who
wants to go and mess around with that
right
so we apply numba by using the jit
decorator which basically will compile
this down to machine level code now the
thing that you don't see is the for loop
we abstracted that away in a different
iteration of this code but just to show
you what the actual tax logic looks like
this is a very common scenario where you
know there's all these variables in this
input and it's an if else if this status
variable for example one of these
variables represents marital status and
so you know your particular tax burden
is going to change depending on your
marital status that kind of thing and
then some very simple arithmetic and
then do a calculation and then return
the answer so that's great but wait
there's more number can do a lot of
really cool things and I'm going to
continue to put the this number logo
like this until number actually a number
team actually creates a logo because
it's been it's been around for like
three years now and they literally have
no logo so I think we should all just do
this until that will incentivize a
behavior that we want which is for them
to create a number logo but ok so
there's a common pattern here they're
like I said we have 150,000 rows of data
every row has about 200 columns right so
it's just a big table of data and the
every single tax law looks exactly the
same thing for for you know every row in
this data set do a bunch of operations
expressions on the elements of that row
so you know B sub I C sub I etc etc it
all looks exactly the same so we want to
take advantage of that and and lower the
burden for our domain experts who are
going to be implementing this tax logic
so so and then the other part of it is
you know the complexity of this all lies
in the number of variables I just showed
you basically but what the math looks
like I mean it's an if-else another the
problem is that a lot of these tax laws
or a particular you know deduction or
credit or whatever you know it takes
about 40 inputs and then for various
reasons we return maybe five or ten of
those
arguments and it's just a lot of typing
so what can we do there well what we did
was we created a custom decorator called
iterate get that uses the standard [ __ ]
underneath the covers and what that does
is it does a few things one is that it
handles this boiler or this boilerplate
code of wrapping the functions and we do
that we do that at import time so so we
don't really see a performance hit from
this but what we do is we have some
boilerplate code that says okay get this
column out of this data frame and
iterate over it and and and then you
know put the answer back or whatever so
i'll show you in the next slide more
specifically what I'm talking about but
from the caller's perspective all that
you do when you call this function is
give those two arguments that I that I
showed in the picture before the the
parameters which is the tack the current
tax policy whether that's the default or
yours and then the records which is
really the puff file so the caller calls
it like this but the function actually
looks like this so all those arguments
you know in this for in this case like
SSI and D and Mars and easy row 2500
those are just column names for data
frames and those columns exist somewhere
in either in params or records so what
we do is we have some code that when the
caller calls a function we go and find
the right column of that name pull it
out and then we have a for loop that you
know it's a very boilerplate for loop
code that we construct at import time
you know at function declaration time
and then the inner what's the function
that's called in the inner for loop is
what the user has written here and
basically we will do the you know pies
for them so they don't have to do that
so all of that this basically will pull
data out of a data frame arm do the for
loop for you and jit it so that it is
you know runs at compile time speeds but
this is the only thing that you have to
type is at iterate yet so that basically
explains everything there we get the
resulting function that comes from
before
rapping shuffles it arguments in and
other data frames and it provides this
this implicit iteration is very much
like a SAS environment which I don't
know if people are too familiar with SAS
but those are our domain experts who are
coding up a lot of this tax logic our
have a SAS background so that that
implicit iteration provides a
programming environment that's very
comfortable for them and allows them to
very quickly take go from you know
what's in their head of how this tax
credit works to to making code so if
that's useful for you there's some links
at the end to where our github repos are
and maybe you can you know use that same
idea but not everyone's a coder and we
want people who are not coders to use
tax calc and do their own policy
microsimulation and so that's where
we're going to show you the tax brain
which is the web accessible version of
this tax calc python package on ospc org
so I'll show you that right now so it's
at OSP Sea Org definitely invite you to
go check out the website and get going
with this if you go to ww SPC org please
enter your email address in here and you
can register as a new user of the
website which will give you access to
the web app so you can just put your
email address in here and then you'll
receive an email with a confirmation
link click on the link go to the website
and set up your password and then you're
good to go and once you've logged in you
just click on the app's link here which
takes you to actually i could probably
just maximize that so you can see
everything yeah so this is tax brain
which is the web accessible version of
tax calc and how it works is basically
all the different inputs that are
possible to add in in code we just have
a box for them and it's pre-populated
with the you know 2015 default values
right we have a little hover over that
tell you you know
okay this is a you know form 1040 line
42 etc and all that kind of stuff so if
you wanted to so for example 4 2015 the
personal exemption is set at four
thousand dollars so what you can do is
change that this is this is my policy
change I would like to change it to
starting in 2015 the new personal
exemption number is 42 hundred dollars
and this little flag here is basically
to say do I want that to be indexed with
inflation so the default is that it
would would increase with inflation
rates and we have a set certain set
inflation rates but if you just wanted
to have that as a flat 4200 for the next
ten simulation years you can do that but
we'll leave it as a default and then you
can go on to the next the next area you
know and and so you can get all the way
down here to you know capital gains tax
personal income tax you could change the
top personal income tax rate right so
it's at point three nine six we could
change that to something like that and
ok and then keep going on down when
you're ready to go you just hit show me
the results and it'll start doing the
computation so it does that that Delta
of you know the standard tax law versus
your change for ten budget years and
then we will you know compute some basic
statistics about that there's some
pandas stuff happening and it should be
done here in just a couple more seconds
but what we do is yeah so here we are so
you've got ten budget years right
starting in 2015 up to 20 24 and just as
a general summary it shows that if you
implemented that that policy change you
would get a 13 point 6 extra dollars in
your in the coffer so to speak for the
government for the year 2015 and all the
way up and then we have a whole bunch of
statistics and data that these policy
analysts are very interested in um so
this would be the difference between so
this is the Delta right where we broken
it down by a GI desa so adjusted gross
income des house so the highest earners
are here the lowest earners are there so
we just adjusted the top income tax
bracket so the people who are going to
have tax increase our over in this area
but we also raised the exemption so
people who had a tax cut or over in here
and so on so now we have the Delta right
difference between base and these are
planned by just income bin right so just
straight adjusted gross income bin where
this is in thousands of dollars and then
actual statistics on the two plans so
here's what the base plan does by a GI
decile here's what your plan does this
is let's see oh and then now we've been
it by straight in [ __ ] buckets and so on
like that so you can go through this and
you can do that for you know all ten
budget years you can look at on that
typically probably people are not going
to you know look around on the website
at all this stuff they made me want to
run some statistics on that or something
so you can save the output as a CSV
right and then if you wanted to record
what inputs you chose you the parameters
that you chose we would save those
inputs as CSV so that's that's pretty
much how it works right now and so so
please do go w WS pc org and register
and you can start playing around with
the tax brain so i'm going to try and
get back into presenter view okay
so how does this all work how do we put
it together it's a pretty standard web
app in many ways we use Django to host
the website celery it can raise your
hand if you've heard of celery okay just
a couple people so it's it's a
distributed computing system so this is
actually the system that's that's going
to help us have a responsive website but
then we need to go and have it some
tasks done to do the actual calculation
so we organized all that with with
celery and for us one task is that one
budget year delta so we had so each time
I did someone comes and does a
simulation we have ten tasks that need
to be done for now and celery needs some
kind of message brokering system so we
use we use Redis for that so the first
thing that we tried can I just get a
show of hands everyone who's familiar
with with Heroku as a basic okay so so
many people so it's a platform as a
service so you just think AWS plus some
extra features that are easy to turn on
that maybe cost a little bit more than
AWS so we just said well let's just do
everything with Heroku seems pretty easy
so with Heroku when you want to add
extra services you need a thing called
Heroku add-ons so you if you want a
database you use a Roku database add-on
so we needed to use Redis so for our
choice we use Redis green and that
seemed to work great for us and then
with AWS you know you have these ec2
instances but in Heroku you they use
this word I know right so we have one
web Dinah which is their standard sort
of generic Dino for hosting the Django
portion of the app and then we would
spin up these additional dinos that were
celery worker dinos that would do our
work and they're connected through Redis
so the result of that was that it was
not great and the reason is because for
the kind of workloads that we were doing
only the PX ty knows which are the most
sort of high performance dine dinos in
the Heroku world could really handle the
work and and so if you have any kind of
workload and and this is I think it's
very relevant for this audience the
kinds of workloads that this audience
does is probably not going to work
well with Heroku dinos if you have a
high memory watermark of some kind or
very computationally intensive kind of
workload it's not that we found that the
performance was was not great and also
these these PX dinos are very expensive
and they just didn't perform as well as
some of the other options so we said
okay well we want let's keep the good
parts of her okay we like some some
parts of Heroku but the workers we're
just going to farm that out to AWS so we
did that and the the architecture looks
pretty much like this now where we have
some number of AWS worker nodes and they
the the Django application talks to
those worker nodes through HTTP so we
basically have sort of tax calc as a web
service and we split the cat the
calculation overall the budget years and
then recombine the the results when
everything's done so what are those
worker nodes look like well they pretty
much look like this we have flask
running so that we can have these web
endpoints to you know start the work and
get the results back on the worker node
itself we have one process running flask
right so that it can be responsive to as
web requests come in and then we run
celery again with you know Redis
underneath and then the tax calculator
is as on the node installed ready to do
the work so it's a it's a stateless API
kind of a restful kind of thing but
there's really only three there's only
three endpoints which is one start the
work which is just post and we have a
start job is that it is the ticket done
yet so as you saw it was waiting there
the website is really just asking the
nodes is this particular budget you're
done and it's at the beginning it has
ten task to start and then tend to find
out when they're done and then when the
answer is yes the we do have the result
Gill go ahead and give it to me which we
you know get a blob of JSON back which
is the sort of calculated and values and
then we assemble it all and then display
this is all deployed with salt and
services running with with systemd on
amazon box
this is it's cheap enough now that we
can have a surplus of these workers and
if some of them go down you know we just
round-robin through available nodes for
all the work that needs to be done so if
some of the nodes go down it's going to
take longer because they'll have to do
one task and then get tasked with
another one and that kind of thing but
it provides this graceful degradation of
service if you are interested in using
numba it with the celery system I would
really suggest that you write a make a
little note here if you think about how
celery workers work there a process that
sitting there saying I'm ready for a new
work to come to me and then a task comes
to them and they need to call your
number eyes function right to to do that
work well it's a jitter right so what
happens is a new task comes and the
default behavior of celery is to
actually execute your task in a separate
fort process right so so the worker is
its own process right but then it Forks
a process to do your task and that's so
that if your task for example had a
memory exception or did something
terrible you haven't killed the whole
worker so in a jit kind of environment
you fork to process and then it needs to
get your code do the work and then give
you the answer and then that process
goes away the next time it gets a task
it Forks the process jits the work and
does it and so on and so on so you you
are jetting every single time so celery
has a workaround for this you can use a
threaded pool instead of and so it will
spawn a new thread instead of forking a
process using the g event library so the
way that you turn that on is with this
which I'm not sure you can see ya it's
that at the bottom there Dash P event
lid is the way to turn on that behavior
so just a little tip for that so this is
very exciting announcement for for us
and for OSP see all of the code that now
runs OS pc org is public and so so all
the the JavaScript and the CSS the
Django templates and all this
distributed tax execution is available
on github now at this at this site so if
you have some front-end skills or you
want to try
out your front end skills you know
please submit we're actively seeking
pull requests so so you get a free
website today everyone so you didn't
know that so yeah just talking a little
bit about deployment because the devil
is always in the details of these things
I mean that's great to throw up
something on a website and now people
can use it but the issue is that this is
an actively maintained and and developed
resource right so how do we you know put
this up in a timely fashion and have the
fact that people are going to be
changing this asset the tax calc package
and we want people to have access to
that so to start off just to reiterate
we do use Heroku for deployment you know
it's very nice get push heroku master
push to deploy is kind of the Heroku
mindset and it's great a few months ago
I found out that people were you know
trying to do you know for example I want
to set up my machine learning system on
Heroku that's a great idea and I want to
use Python to do it well all the forums
are in in the Heroku developer area
we're basically hey I'm having trouble
compiling CyHi hey I'm having troubling
doing all this because the way that
Heroku works is that it's will it will
detect ok you are you want to run a
Django application you want to run these
Python this Python code and you have a
requirements on txt and so a build pack
is the Heroku speak for this these
scripts that will launch your app and it
will that is the thing that's going to
pip install everything that you have so
when you say pip install syfy on these
Heroku nodes that that's not going to
work it's going to invoke a compiler and
the linkage is not going to be right and
it's not gonna going to be successful
for you so you can actually have a
specify a custom build pack and so the
recommendation that i would i would have
for you is to use kenneth Rice's Conda
build pack kenneth rights of requests
package he works at Heroku and he's put
together this this bill pack that allows
you to install Conda packages for if you
have things like scikit-learn or CyHi or
NL 2k or really anything that has side
para numpy at the base of it
and is something like that this will
allow you to Conda install the packages
that you know have the binding that have
a binary dependency and then you can
also pip install your other packages so
that's kind of on the Heroku land in
deploying tax brain itself the like i
said this package changes very
frequently the other thing is that it
was very important to our sponsor that
that anyone should be able to reproduce
these results if I go in and and type
and do what I just did on the tax brain
I need to be able to share that with
people and anyone needs to be able to
reproduce it and we have very simple
policy for running the tax brain which
is that whatever you produce on tax
brain should be easily reproducible on a
local machine on any platform we just
want to say that we guarantee that
that's going to work so how do we do
that well the step one is you know you
want to have versioning done properly so
i would very very strongly recommend
that people use version year for their
versioning um is anyone can just raise
the hand if you use version here ok it's
great it's a total drop in I guess you
might call it a drop in module it's
simply a drop in solution to your python
package that does awesome things with
versioning and the way that it works is
that you use get tagged to tag a
particular release right and then the
get archive command is what will enable
the version your magic and I you know
you can just go look through the
documentation there but the bottom line
is that you use git archive will then
take that tag repo and then produce a
version package on your local machine so
now that this version package is ready
to go um you want to produce packages
for so that anyone can install it and
for us we want to support mac windows
and linux and 32 and 64-bit on those
last two so we use condom build to build
those packages and then upload the
packages to anaconda or would formerly
been start work so that's a way of
making the binary packages freely
available to anyone who wants to use
them so for example you could invoke
this
askim and at the bottom here Khan
installed SC used the ospc channel on
anaconda org to download tax calc and it
will bring all the dependencies on to
your machine as well yeah and then when
we at deployment time because we have
that custom bill pack we we have a you
know the the Heroku push will do the con
install of the latest version so what we
learned there is Heroku is very compute
is a very expensive for compute and
memory intensive applications get tagged
plus version air and Connor build an
anaconda org really allows us to have a
transparent cross-platform deployment
with reproducible results and a public
history of changes I would very
recommend if you want to do this kind of
operation that you have this numerical
work that you want to make available
through the web be aware that your users
are not going to wait too long we need
to find a way to be responsive to you
know the user idea of you interacting
with your package through a browser so
you probably want to chop your work up
in some kind of way that works well for
a web service so in other words you know
yeah if you can partition your problem
into smaller units and then assemble the
answer when it's done that might not be
the least amount of computational work
but it'll scale a lot better so what's
coming up next for this project we're
deploying a new kind of model a more
involved macroeconomic model health care
models social security module models we
want to have some visualizations maybe
with bouquet or something and lots of
things happening with the tax cut
package in ospc org if you see a Help
Wanted label on an issue you too could
be a good guy and make things better so
please do give it a give it a look I
just want to acknowledge Matt Jensen
who's here in the audience I was our
managing director of ospc and thank him
for sponsoring all this work so there's
our github repos please go check them
out and thanks a lot for listening
you